[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
meine generation ist krieg in europa und
denkbar geworden und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass das so bleibt es ist unsere
verdammte pflicht und aufgabe als staats
und regierungschefs zu verhindern dass
es in europa zu einer kriegerischen
eskalation kommt der bundeskanzler in
moskau viel höher gesteckt könnte das
ziel nicht sein ein antrittsbesuch vor
dem hintergrund des russischen truppen
auf maß an der grenze zur ukraine
vor dem hintergrund dass die usa warnen
jeden moment könne ein krieg beginnen
guten abend in hallen am ende eines
langen tages mit großen erwartungen mit
großer sorge müssen wir alle zwischen
den zeilen lesen nach vier stunden
gespräch scholz putin am langen tisch
nach einer gemeinsamen pressekonferenz
gibt es zumindest das bereitschaft
weiter zu reden es gibt auch anzeichen
dass russland teile seiner truppen
zurück in die kasernen beordert
auch wenn noch unklar ist wie nachhaltig
das ist ein tag also zum vorläufigen
durchatmen vorerst wohl kein krieg aber
auch kein frieden christiansen hat ihn
in moskau erlebt
was in diesen tagen besonders auffällt
in moskau die tische werden immer länger
und die gespräche auch sechs meter
abstand zwischen olaf scholz und
wladimir putin offiziell wegen corona
und nicht um die inhaltliche distanz
aufzuzeigen wie es heißt der besuch des
deutschen kanzlers heute in moskau der
vorläufige höhepunkt des diplomatie
marathons bei dem man sich fragen kann
sieht man die zielgerade oder wird der
konflikt zwischen russland und der
ukraine zum gefährlichen dauerlauf
scholz und putin betonen ihre
bereitschaft zum dialog
natürlich wollen wir keinen kredit
deshalb haben wir unsere vorschläge
unterbreitet ein gespräch zu starten das
dazu führen soll dass wir uns über das
prinzip der gleichen sicherheit für alle
einschließlich der von russland
dieses defizit schuss gramm
begleitet wird diese forderungen vom
massiven russischen truppenaufmarsch bei
dem russland die bedrohung kleinredet
der kanzler diese aber nochmal benennt
sowie die generelle unterschiede ich
will noch etwas sagen zu der situation
der gespräche
die position sind unterschiedlich dass
es klar geworden darum haben wir uns um
andere unterhalten das ist auch richtig
aber es ist immerhin so dass
mittlerweile gesprochen wird und ich
finde richtig dass die nato die
europäische union auf die briefe
russlands geantwortet haben und es ist
ein gutes zeichen dass russland zwar
nicht einverstanden ist mit der antwort
aber sagt da sind ein paar gute dinge
drin und umgekehrt ist es so dass mit
den vorstellungen die russland
formuliert hat die nato die eu auch hier
nicht einverstanden sind aber finden da
sind ein paar punkte drin über die es
nun miteinander zu reden die durch es
ist in teilen auch ein schlagabtausch
zwischen kanzler und präsident die
botschaft dialogbereitschaft aber
standhaftigkeit bei den eigenen position
wir haben die nato infrastruktur direkt
vor unserem haus außerdem wird die frage
des beitritts der ukraine diskutiert sie
sagen ich wird nicht morgen sein wann
dann übermorgen
was ändert sich für uns in historischer
perspektive
ist er absolut nichts tut
mit soooooo scholz kontert wie schon
gestern in kiew betonte der kanzler dass
ein nato-beitritt der ukraine gar nicht
zur debatte stünde das ist kein thema
das uns wahrscheinlich in unseren ämtern
begegnen wird wieder so lange wir sie
ausüben ich weiß jetzt nicht wie lange
der präsident vor hat im amt zu sagen da
war ich jedenfalls habe das gefühl das
könnte länger dauern aber nicht ewig
eine
anspielung auf den ewigen putin scholz
beklagte noch die verschlechterung der
menschenrechtslage in russland der fall
navalny oder die verbotene
menschenrechtsorganisation memorial
bei einem pressegespräch mit deutschen
journalisten kommt scholz dann noch mal
auf das thema nato-beitritt der ukraine
und es ist deshalb eine frage der
führungsfähigkeit aller bezahlen in
russland in der ukraine in der nato
dafür zu sorgen dass wir nicht eine
absurde situation erleben die dann um so
etwas ginge das gar nicht gegenstand des
weltgeschehens der nächsten zeit während
der angekündigten teilrückzug des
russischen militärs von der grenze heute
moskaus kompromissangebot kanzler scholz
und präsident putin sind sich trotz
distanz zumindest beim wunsch nach
dialog näher gekommen es dürfte nicht
das letzte lange gespräch gewesen sein
am langen tisch oder woanders
theo koll beobachtet den bundeskanzler
auf dieser reise teo genannt nach moskau
ist er jetzt bei den deutschen so etwas
wie erleichterung zu spüren heute
absolut ich glaube das kann man wirklich
bejahen auch wenn in vielen punkten
offensichtlich keine übereinstimmung
gefunden wurde muss sich vergewaltigen
morgen sollte eigentlich der tag der
möglichen in version sein so jedenfalls
die amerikanischen geheimdienste und
jetzt haben wir eine situation wo der
ukrainische präsident gesetzentwürfe
zugesagt hat für die ost ukraine für
wahlen autonomie die den russen ganz
besonders wichtig sind und wir haben
einen teilrückzug von truppen erlebt wie
viel symbolik davon es muss man mal
abwarten aber immerhin gibt es ganz
klare fortschritte der kanzler hat
gesagt wir haben miteinander geredet wir
wollen weiter reden es gibt ansätze dazu
also hier ist erleichterung zu spüren
wenn auch natürlich verhalten weil im
wesentlichen ist man nicht übereinstimmt
hatte in der bundeskanzler leute einen
draht gefunden so wladimir putin
also um ehrlich zu sein da würde ich ein
großes fragezeichen setzen da haben sich
nicht zwei babys gefunden da gab es
keine vornamen er hat ihnen sogar auf
den arm genommen bei einer stelle der
geht um die nato erweiterung richtung
ukraine die putin sehr sehr wichtig ist
dass das nicht passiert und
scholz hat gesagt das ist eigentlich
kein thema das werden wir beide in
unserer amtszeit nicht mehr erleben und
dann guckt er zu putin und sagte na ja
ich weiß ja nicht wie lange sie noch im
amt bleiben wollen was putin nicht so
witzig fand ich habe ihn mir da in dem
moment genau angeschaut also das sind
zwei die haben offen miteinander geredet
aber sie haben auch beide das
bewusstsein wir haben offen miteinander
geredet und wir haben uns klartext
gesagt damit wir auch von dort aus
weiter reden können theo wie kann man
denn überhaupt diese atmosphäre da heute
beschreiben in moskau wir sehen auf den
fernsehbildern zunächst mal einen
geradezu absurd langen tisch ja der war
im grunde auch ein ganz wichtiges symbol
de ging es im wesentlichen eigentlich um
pcr tests denn der kreml hat verlangt
von uns mit reisen journalisten aber
auch vom kanzler dass er nicht nur drei
pcs vor der reise machte sondern auch
noch ein im kreml da hat aber olaf
scholz gesagt das mache ich nicht ich
mache meinen eigenen pc erst im flugzeug
hatte alles dabei die ärztin der
botschaft kam und makro ging es auch
schon so der hat auch gesagt nein das
mache ich nicht ich beuge mich da nicht
den regeln des kreml das führte aber
dazu dass putin gesagt hat so dann
setzen wir uns eben an diesen sechs
meter tisch und die entsprechende
distanz also in gewisser weise ein
symbol für das ringen um respekt der
nationen tirol hat sich ein dank für
diese beobachtungen heute in moskau
gerne
ja einiges an symbolik also dabei selbst
wenn es nur um pcr tests geht christoph
heusgen war lange außenpolitischer
berater von bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel un immer dabei wenn es um die
verhandlungen mit präsident putin zur
ukraine ging er hat auch das minsker
abkommen mit verhandelt dass sie heute
wieder in aller munde war herausgerissen
guten abend wir haben sie was war das
heute aus ihrer sicht ein guter tag für
den frieden und ich war nicht bei den
gesprächen dabei ich habe nur die
pressekonferenz gesehen die
körpersprache gesehen die themen die
besprochen worden sind und ich glaube
das war heute letztlich in denen unter
den umständen in denen wir leben in
guter tag sie sagen sie haben die
körpersprache gesehen für uns ist ja der
russische präsident immer so ein
bisschen oder sogar sehr mysteriös
werden sie das bedeuten was er da heute
gesagt hat auch wie er sich gegeben hat
ist ihnen jetzt klarer was putin will
und wie weit er bereit wäre zu gehen
das kann man daraus nicht sehen putin
hat mit sicherheit langfristige ziele
die langfristigen ziel enthalten auch
dass er sich dass das sowjetische die
sowjetunion unter russischem gewand
irgendwie wiederbeleben will aber ich
glaube er hat gesehen dass er jetzt bei
denen bei seinem jetzigen vorgehen in
sachen ukraine dass er dagegen eine
breite wand von staaten gestoßen ist und
die sich eng abstimmen die sich bemühen
auch auswege zu finden
und mein eindruck war heute schon dass
man versucht jetzt auch da doch auf dem
verhandlungswege weiterzukommen und was
sich gut fand auch das bei den bei der
pressekonferenz gesprochen wurde ist
über wirtschaftsbeziehungen über die
wiederbelebung eines
zivilgesellschaftlichen dialogs also das
klang schon weniger weniger militant als
es vorher geklungen hatte und dann soll
es ja einen zumindest teilweisen
truppenabzug der russen geben ist das
aus ihrer sicht ein ganz klares
entspannungssignal oder eine nebelkerze
nein ich glaube das ist schon ein
entspannungssignal ganz sicher aber wir
sind noch nicht über dem berg das ist
jetzt ein erstes entspannungssignal es
geht in die richtige richtung aber das
kann ja jederzeit wieder umgedreht
werden aber erstmals wir sind auf gutem
weg aber nicht überm berg sagen sie dann
stellt sich natürlich gleich die
anschlussfrage wie geht es denn jetzt
weiter da war heute immer wieder dass
minsk abkommen bemüht worden das ja von
beiden seiten aktuell nicht eingehalten
wird also weder von der ukraine noch von
russland in einfachen worten vielleicht
mal heraus können sie haben es mit
verhandelt welchen ausweg bietet dieses
abkommen das abkommen das ist in einer
nachtaktion von abends bis zum kommenden
märz bis zum morgen darauf verhandelt
worden ist letztlich ein umfassender
friedensplan das enthält vom
waffenstillstand und beobachtung durch
osze bis hin zu wahlen und veränderung
der verfassung sehr viel wasser die
möglichkeit zu einem frieden bieten
würde es hakt an allen seiten aber wenn
man jetzt wieder sagt so wir wollen
wieder dass das minsk kommt beleben wir
wollen darüber verhandeln dann ist das
dann ist das ein guter weg aber warum
sollte ausgerechnet in der aktuellen
doch sehr angespannten situationen
dieses abkommen jetzt mehr chancen haben
als in all den jahren zuvor bei
verhandeln immer besser ist als kämpfen
das heißt man kann sich wieder dran
setzen man kann versuchen kann man beim
waffenstillstand fortschritte machen
kann man im hinblick auf die
ausgestaltung der autonomie
fortschritte machen also es gibt immer
möglichkeiten wenn der politische wille
ist teilbereiche dieses abkommen zu
umzusetzen und wenn das jetzt ernsthaft
unternommen wird dass das nochmal die
format hat ja auf der ebene der berater
auch schon lange stunden getagt wenn man
da jetzt sagt also wir wollen jetzt ein
paar konkrete schritte machen dann dann
ist das positiv haben sie den eindruck
dass jetzt auch mehr druck auf die
ukraine im spiel hat der bundeskanzler
da möglicherweise heute auch
zugeständnisse aus der ukraine nach
moskau transportiert
dieses minsker abkommen wird von beiden
seiten nicht erfüllt und ich will nur
auf einen punkt hinweisen der glaube ich
ganz ganz wichtig ist zu beginn des
minsker abkommens stand die
verpflichtung russlands zu einem
waffenstillstand und er sollte nach
einer bestimmten zeit eingehalten werden
und russland hat das nicht gemacht
sondern hat noch mehrere tage länger
gekämpft um einen strategischen ort zu
gewinnen und diese dieses missachten von
minsk hat sehr viel misstrauen in im
parlament in der rada in kiew verursacht
sodass es so immer schwierig war schon
für präsident paul cheng co diese
gesetzesänderung durchzusetzen wenn
jetzt auch russland dieses vertrauen
schafft indem also die beobachter ihre
arbeit machen können indem der
waffenstillstand eingehalten wird dann
in der tat kann auch kate und muss auch
kiew liefern ganz kurz noch herauskommen
sie haben haben einfach dieses gesprächs
gesagt sie haben eigentlich ein
vorsichtig positives gefühl nach diesem
tag
wann was würden sie sagen wann können
wir mit einer kompletten entspannung
rechnen dauert das jetzt monate jahre
oder geht es schneller nein ich glaube
wir können mit dem wenn wenn diese
manöver beendet sind wenn die truppen
tatsächlich auch abgezogen sind wenn man
sieht es wird verhandelt wie der
normandie format ist wird verhandelt
dann vielleicht auch im
nato-russland-rat über
vertrauensbildende maßnahmen man kann ja
auch sehr viel über abrüstungs projekte
sprechen wenn wieder richtig am
verhandlungstisch gesessen wird wenn es
atmosphäre ich auch besser wird dann
glaube ich sind wir auf gutem weg
christoph heusgen lange außenpolitischer
berater von bundeskanzlerin merkel hat
viel mit putin verhandelt künftiger
leiter der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
herausgehen vielen dank für das gespräch
vielen dank ihr sie was
das gespräch aber aus termingründen kurz
vor dieser sendung aufgezeichnet so der
us-präsident der ist noch nicht
überzeugt die usa hätten nicht
verifiziert dass russische einheiten
sich tatsächlich zurückzögen sagte joe
biden gerade eben in einer
fernsehansprache
eine russische invasion in der ukraine
bleibe so beiden absolut möglich
deutschland russland da gab es heute im
kreml neben politik und konflikt noch
ein schlagwort das immer wieder gefallen
ist bei putin bei scholz das große
potenzial der wirtschaftsbeziehungen
es geht um pipelines es geht um gas und
öl es geht um energiepreise und es geht
um druckmittel dass beide seiten
versuchen einzusetzen jeweils auf ihre
art und für ihre ziele wie peter kunz
zeigt
nord stream 2 die schweren röhren in der
ostsee dem ukraine russland konflikt
vielleicht politisches übergewicht
bekommen haben noch fließt nicht
hindurch ohne sie würde europa also
erstmal nichts fehlen putin hätte die
pipeline gerne um bei russischen
gaslieferungen die ukraine außen vor zu
lassen aber täter ein aus im wirklich so
weh
dass wir nicht die sanktionen die
wirklich treffen würden wirklich
schmerzhaft treffen würde russland
tatsächlich einen stopp der zahlung für
energielieferung wenn man putin wirklich
weh tun möchte musste man eigentlich
insbesondere das geschäft treffen weil
das sozusagen eine viel wichtigere rolle
für den start aus sagt und auch
eigentlich für die finanzierung von den
verteidigungsausgaben hat die
finanzierung von kriegen relevant ist öl
beziehen auch die amerikaner aus
russland ein verzicht ist für sie aber
bisher keine frage gefragt nach nord
stream 2 wird allerdings immer es ist
das symbolische sanktions thema nummer
eins den bundeskanzler scholz womöglich
aus dem weg geht auch aus juristischer
vor sich die privatwirtschaftlichen
verträge sind über sehr lange zeiträume
abgeschlossen worden regressforderungen
werden stattfinden werden wahrscheinlich
auch dann stattfinden wenn wir zum
beispiel kein erdgas merkt nehmen und
dieses auch nicht mehr bezahlen
einkäufer boykott gegen russische
lieferungen den gaspreis würde es weiter
nach oben treiben zum ende des winters
könnte uns knappheit drohen aber keine
eiszeit daheim den flüssiggastanker
werden derzeit schon von asien richtung
europa umgeleitet sie fahren den preis
nach diese tanker sind zwar da auf den
meeren stehen aber dann schlange vor den
terminals wir haben terminals an der
ostsee und auch an der nordsee die haben
noch freie kapazitäten gelegenen polen
oder in frankreich wir haben relativ
viel auch im mittelmeer weil man über
das mittelmeer relativ viel schippert
aber dann müssen wir das innerhalb des
gasnetz systems verteilen und aus
südeuropa nach nordeuropa da sind die
verbindung nicht so gut gute verbindung
dafür war nord stream zweimal geplant
worden mit der großen abhängigkeit von
russland beim flüssiggas geht aber auch
nichts ohne ausländische partner ein
eigenes an lande terminal besitzt die
bundesrepublik nicht die ampel koalition
möchte langfristig gas nur noch als
brückentechnologie nutzen fürs klima
nord stream 2 hätte dafür durchaus wert
wenn wir davon ausgehen dass wir
längerfristig
auf gas verzichten werden würden wir
aber auch mit nord stream 2 auf die
möglichkeit einer umrüstung von einer
gaspipeline in einer wasserstoff ball
klein eigentlich verzichten welches
wiederum eigentlich eine eine top
priorität auf der agenda der
bundesregierung ist was
nach dem 2 betrifft so hat kanzler
scholz heute in moskau klar gemacht da
soll so lange frieden bleibt keiner hier
in die röhre schauen
seit wochen beobachtet die welt die lage
zwischen russland und der ukraine ganz
genau hält den atem an fürchtet die
eskalation die welt mit ausnahme von
russland selbst die staatsmedien dort
zeichnen ein sehr eigenes bild der
situation was ihre soldaten gerade tun
bleibt den meisten russinnen und russen
verborgen was sie erfahren hat mit der
tatsächlichen lage in der ukraine nicht
viel zu tun wie anne gellinek jetzt
zeigt
der mann heißt dimitri kissel und er ist
putins chef propagandist zur besten
sendezeit am sonntagabend erklärt er den
russischen zuschauern im staatsfernsehen
wie sie die welt zu sehen haben
dauerbrenner die wahrheit über die
ukraine
reportage aus dem don was auf der seite
der pro russischen separatisten der
reporter berichtet dass die ukrainische
armee in der abtrünnigen provinz
gräueltaten verübeln und zeigt fotos von
verfremdeten leichen und sommer bilder
von einem angeblich misshandelt wie man
tapfere patrioten die die
selbsternannten republik gegen die
ukrainische armee verteidigen fixen
fähnchen in eine karte um die übermacht
der ukraine zu demonstrieren es müssen
120000 man sein sagen sie der mann im
unterstand berichtet von kindern die die
ukraine an strommasten aufknüpfen die
chefredakteurin des russischen ausland
senders rte weint fast in einer talkshow
wegen der lage in der ukraine
wenn russland gezwungen sein sollte sich
einzumischen dann nicht um einen krieg
zu beginnen sondern um ihn zu beenden
sollen wir warten bis die ukraine dort
konzentrationslager errichtet künstler
wie der von den truppen die seit drei
monaten ein stück weiter westlich auf
russischer seite stehen erfährt der
zuschauer kein sterbens wort dafür aber
sieht der deutsche ministerien in
kriegs- montur und immer wieder
amerikanische waffenlieferungen an inka
ihnen
die feinde sind ukraine amerikaner
manchmal auch die brut da putin der
bevölkerung kein leben auf normalem
niveau keine soziale absicherung bieten
kann präsentiert er ihnen feinde gegen
die man kämpfen muss
die ukraine ein gescheiterter staat ohne
eigene geschichte so die propaganda in
moskau und petersburg wissen die
menschen ist besser aber draußen im land
wirkt die staatliche beschallung die
mehrheit der russen glaubt laut umfragen
tatsächlich das an einem krieg in der
ukraine die amerikaner schuld wären und
auch das kann propaganda gestern
überrumpelt putin das land mit einem
schlecht gespielten dialog vor kameras
mit außenminister lawrow weiter
verhandeln na gut weiter verhandeln ein
präsident ohne freie presse braucht
keine begründung für einen plötzlichen
schwenk diese propaganda lässt alle
türen und fenster offen
für putin um verschiedene optionen vom
angriff bis hin zum rückzug
rechtfertigen zu lassen ein marsch oder
entspannungssignale das russische
staatsfernsehen lässt keine eindeutige
interpretation zu wie auch entschieden
wird am ende von einem mann im kreml
wie kann es jetzt weitergehen dazu hat
gundula gause fragen an den cdu
außenpolitik experte norbert röttgen
nachher hier im heute journal
update und auch der bundespräsident ist
heute unterwegs in sachen russland
ukraine konflikt und das hast du gut
verfolgt frank walter steinmeier ist
nach lettland gereist und hat dort
präsident leer wird getroffen mit dabei
deutliche worte der solidarität lettland
und die anderen baltischen staaten
könnten sich auf den beistand
deutschlands verlassen an ein schnelles
ende des konflikts glaubt der
bundespräsident nicht und betonte dass
im falle einer eskalation eine
entschlossene und gemeinsame antwort
gefunden werden müsse
nach der verheerenden flutkatastrophe im
sommer will nordrhein westfalen jetzt
seinen katastrophenschutz verbessern
innenminister reue hat dazu heute einen
15 punkte plan vorgestellt er soll in
zukunft zum beispiel ein landeseigenes
krisenreaktionszentrum geben außerdem
mehr dezentrale depots für material und
geräte und im notfall soll es künftig
möglich sein direkt in den hörfunk
einzugreifen um die bevölkerung zu
warnen die flutkatastrophe im juli
verwüstete in nordrhein-westfalen ganze
orte 49 menschen starben dabei
das eu parlament hat dem ex afg chef und
europa abgeordneten jörg leuten die
parlamentarische immunität entzogen
damit ist nun der weg frei für mögliche
strafrechtliche ermittlungen hintergrund
sind unter anderem mutmaßlich illegale
parteispenden im landtagswahlkampf 2000
16 leuten bezeichnete die
verdächtigungen als haltlos und
unzutreffend
gestern abend haben gegner der korona
politik erneut vor den wohnhäusern von
politikern demonstriert betroffen war
unter anderem baden württembergs
ministerpräsident kretschmann und auch
vor dem wohnhaus des oberbürgermeisters
von halberstadt in sachsen-anhalt
versammelten sich ca 700 menschen laut
polizei angeführt von rechtsextremen mit
trillerpfeifen fackeln und feuerwerk
oberbürgermeister daniels vater nannte
den vorfall bedrohlich
wochen lang sind die korona zahlen in
deutschland gestiegen doch nun gehen sie
zurück und das seit mehreren tagen die
sieben tage incidents sinkt zum dritten
mal hintereinander und liegt aktuell bei
37,5 das robert koch institut meldet
außerdem
159 1217 neuinfektionen das ist ein
rückgang im wochenvergleich da waren es
noch gut 10.000 fälle mehr ja- und im
gleichen maß wie die zahlen zurückgehen
steigt der ruf nach dem ende der korona
auflagen und es wäre nicht deutschland
es wäre nicht der tag vor einer neuen
ministerpräsidenten konferenz wenn alles
geordnet und übersichtlich liefe und so
ist es dann auch jetzt wie jedes mal die
einen kündigen an die anderen
beschließen schon deutsche föderalismus
in aktion wer da wie agiert und was das
alles für das polit projekt impfpflicht
bedeutet zeigt wie die herrscher ein
bisschen fragt man sich am ende des
tages worüber morgen der bundeskanzler
mit den ministerpräsidentinnen und
präsidenten noch konferieren will dann
heute schon brechen einige mit
lockerungen vor darunter nicht nur der
übliche verdächtige felsenfest überzeugt
wir sind team vorsicht und ihm freiheit
aber nicht team stuhl deswegen ist
wichtig dass wir morgen auf der mpk
weichenstellung und für ganz deutschland
treffen nicht einfach vertagen wir
setzen deswegen heute auch im
bayerischen kabinett sowohl ein signal
in richtung der mpk aber machen auch
unsere eigenen maßnahmen das kabinett
hat sich heute auf einen stufenplan
verständigt dieser sieht insgesamt drei
schritte vor diese schritte werden wir
in jedem fall umsetzen sage dass an der
stelle so deutlich weil wir morgen ja
eine konferenz der
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundesregierung haben auch berlin hat
lockerungs pläne aber transistor
gefordert einen instrumentenkasten über
den 20 märz hinaus damit ist sie nicht
allein im märz endet das
infektionsschutzgesetz auf dem bislang
alles fust es ist gerade die frage was
passiert wenn ich einen hotspot habe
wenn ich ein extrem belastete situation
im krankenhaus in einem altersheim habe
kann man dann entsprechend reagieren und
auch zb besucher beschränkung oder
anderes machen für den notfall und diese
notfall regelung die muss es geben auch
über den zwanzigsten märz hinaus die
länder lockern und stehen weiter vor
einer impflücken lange hatte man gehofft
mit regeln die 2g millionen ungeimpfte
zum impfen zu bewegen diese regeln sind
und bald geschichte und das impf tempo
stoppt deswegen
halte ich nach wie vor eine einer
impfpflicht fest damit wir die
notwendigen
quoten auch erreichen die wir benötigen
nicht damit wir nicht wieder im
nächsten herbst und winter in eine
ähnliche situation kommen darum die
impfpflicht wird gepokert die opposition
sagt verantwortlich sei das kanzleramt
die ampelkoalition sagt verantwortlich
sei das parlament fakt ist bislang
liegen hier nicht alle anträge vor die
debatte verschiebt sich in den märz
zweckoptimismus auf der einen seite ich
bin mir ganz sicher dass wir noch vor
ostern hier abschließen werden auf der
anderen seite attacke vom frisch
gewählten unionsfraktionschef friedrich
merz er hat seine truppe hinter sich in
sachen im register und einer späteren
impfpflicht wir sind natürlich auch zu
kompromissen bereit aber wir sind nicht
mehr bereit handwerklich miserables
arbeit einer bundesregierung die in sich
nicht einig ist und die in sicht nicht
geschlossen ist zu unterstützen
so bleibt am ende des tages so viel die
chancen für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
schwinden und der korona flickenteppich
wird noch bunter und
damit noch mal zurück zu unserem thema
vom anfang dieser sendung die situation
im konflikt russland ukraine wie sehr
das auch die wirtschaft beschäftigt
haben wir gestern schon gesehen bei der
wiesn es heute hammer ja auch heute
hatte der konflikt die märkte fest im
griff allerdings mit anderen
auswirkungen als gestern noch dabei der
dax sah zwischenzeitlich deutlich
eingebrochen heute soll das dagegen
schon wieder etwas anders aus frank
bethmann in frankfurt auf macht was
müssen wir uns da einstellen auf genau
diese schaukelbörse die wir da gerade
erleben es sind ganz nebenbei mehr
gerade diese situation die wie gemacht
sind für kurzfristig agieren der
hedgefonds die also in diese bewegungen
große chancen für gewinne sehen und
durch ihr agieren das auf und ab noch
verstärken so kann der dax seine
vortagsverluste heute komplett
wettmachen auch das russische
aktienbarometer das zuletzt fast 10
prozent einbüßte heute sogar plus 5
prozent ebenfalls am abend wieder im
plus der amerikanische dow jones index
die gegenbewegung bei fast allen was im
volksmund als sicherer hafen bezeichnet
wird werden investoren geld in
sicherheit bringen wollen wie zuletzt
dann kaufen sie gold nach dem höhenflug
verliert die feinunze heute aber fast
ein prozent und der run auf
staatsanleihen wie auf die zehnjährige
bundesanleihe kühlte sich heute
ebenfalls wieder ab besonders starke
reaktion heute beim erdgas der preis
fällt gleich um
16% die furcht vor lieferausfällen fast
wie weggeblasen doch so willkommen jeder
aussicht auf eine friedliche lösung ist
ein händler brachte ist heute auf den
punkt die märkte werden etwas
handfesteres sehen wollen bevor sie die
krise für beendet erklären vielen dank
nach frankfurt
im missbrauchsskandal um den britischen
prinz andrew wird es nun sehr
wahrscheinlich doch nicht zu einem
prozess kommen der prinz und die
klägerin virginia dufry haben sich
außergerichtlich auf eine beilegung der
klage geeinigt die frau hatte dem sohn
von queen elizabeth vorgeworfen sie vor
gut seit jahren als minderjährige
mehrfach sexuell missbraucht zu haben
der palast hat dem prinzen inzwischen
bereits alle militärischen dienst gerade
und schirmherrschaften entzogen
nach dem zusammenstoß von zwei s bahnen
bei münchen laufen die untersuchungen
weiter für technisches versagen gäbe es
bisher keine anzeichen
das sagte der bayerische innenminister
herrmann heute am montagnachmittag waren
die zwei züge auf einem einspurigen
streckenabschnitt frontal kollidiert ein
24 jähriger mann kam dabei ums leben 18
weitere menschen mussten im krankenhaus
behandelt werden und
damit bedanken wir uns für ihr interesse
an diesen nachrichten dienstag ab morgen
freut sich an dieser stelle kollegin
marietta slomka auf sie du bleibst oder
ich bleibe okay ich hab noch einen
kurzen hinweis auf 37 grad gleich nach
unserer olympia berichterstattung in der
reportage geht es heute um jobs mit
ausblick und es gab eine bedingung die
kamera durfte kein einziges mal am boden
sein oder allerdings und gegen 0.15 gibt
es unser heute-journal update mit wohn
oder gase schönen abend ihnen
[Musik]
guten abend in den kommenden 24 stunden
überqueren uns gleich mehrere regen
bender es wird sehr mild und der erste
höhepunkt der kommenden sturm lage der
wird uns wohl am donnerstag früh
erwischen jetzt sind dieser nacht ist es
meist noch ruhig es fällt häufig regen
das erste regenband kommt ihr schon im
westen an und wird bis morgen früh den
alpenrand erreicht haben dann kommt
schon gleich das nächste regenband
hinterher eine kurze regenpause folgt
und dann wird es hier am nachmittag und
zum abend wieder kräftig regnen im
westen heute nacht ist es also
allenfalls an den alten mal klar
deswegen sinken dort die temperaturen
auf plus 1 bis minus 5 grad sonst bleibt
die nacht bei 8 bis 3 grad milder und
morgen erwarten uns höchsttemperaturen
am alpenrand von sechs grad 14 grad
werden es am niederrhein allenfalls
morgen vormittag haben sie in
niederbayern noch eine gewisse chance
auf sonne sonst regnet es fast den
ganzen tag land und das zum teil kräftig
dann kommt die nacht auf donnerstag und
donnerstag früh ist der erste sturm
höhepunkt machen sie sich auf orkanböen
mit mehr als 117 kilometer pro stunde im
harz gefasst auf orkanartige sturmböen
an der küste und schwere sturmböen
selbst im alpenvorland meiden sie wälder
halten sie sich von baugerüsten fern und
vielleicht verschieben sie auch geplante
reisen es gibt auch kräftige schauer am
donnerstag und am freitag nachmittag
kommt das nächste orkantief heran und am
samstag wird sich der warmluft orkan
dann ausgetobt haben guten abend